bueno
[Música]
a escala en parís
braulio moro
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con france24 en español más
de 300 organizaciones incluidos
sindicatos asociaciones de derechos
humanos han lanzado un llamado
internacional pidiendo a las empresas
que producen calzado y ropa deportiva
entre otros se comprometan a no utilizar
trabajo forzado concretamente de la
población wiwa que habita en el noroeste
de china y que han sido duramente
reprimidos por las autoridades de ese
país para hablar de la importancia de
este llamado internacional de cuáles son
esas empresas que están haciendo uso de
trabajo forzado y de cuáles son las
alternativas saludamos aquí en nuestros
estudios han hay la hay alto ni portavoz
del colectivo le titulé ticket que
podríamos traducir como ética sobre la
etiqueta una de las asociaciones que
está haciendo parte de este llamado
internacional no hay la bienvenida a
esta escala en parís gracias toman
logrado ustedes saber cómo fue que
supieron que el gobierno chino está
recurriendo al trabajo forzado obligando
al trabajo forzado a la población muy
cool
bueno es muy difícil de obtener tener
esta información a causa de la opacidad
del gobierno chino pero nuestra fuente
principal de información fue un informe
de una organización australiana que se
llama aspi y que reúna informaciones e
investigaciones y también informaciones
del gobierno chino
mostrando que hay como entre un millón y
un millón y ocho mil 102 dos mil 800 mil
personas de origen uigur que están
utilizando como trabajadores forzados en
empresas fábricas en cine recordemos
precisamente los rigores es una
población de origen nómada que habita en
el noroeste de china en una enorme
superficie la región autónoma de
xinjiang una de las cinco regiones
autónomas de china y efectivamente se
habla de que aproximadamente entre un
millón y un millón 800 mil personas
están obligadas a hacer trabajos
forzados antes de entrar en materia en
hay la usted
el colectivo de tics le ticket que
quiere decir este nombre porque el
nombre mejor dicho y sobre todo cuál es
el trabajo que ustedes realizan es un
colectivo que fue creado en 1995 y es
una reunión de sindicatos de ongs de
educación de organizaciones de educación
popular francesa que quieren que
dediquen su acción a defender los
derechos laborales en las cadenas de
producción a través del mundo y
especialmente en el sector textil y el
nombre viene de su primero objeto
objetivo que era de creer un label
social que puede que
que garantice las condiciones laborales
y el respeto de los derechos humanos
para la ropa que
y llevamos y ahora su principal objetivo
es defender tus derechos laborales y
también de regular la actividad
económica de las transnacionales en un
sector que se funda sobre violaciones
sistemáticas de derechos laborales en el
mundo un aislados decía usted es un
aproximadamente entre un millón un
billón 800 mil personas de origen wilbur
que están siendo obligadas a un trabajo
forzado nos dice usted no es fácil
obtener información que se sabe de las
condiciones de vida de explotación de
esas personas lo que se sabe es que
bueno el gobierno o el gobierno
el gobierno chino publica información es
que estas personas son terroristas o
personas peligrosas que están en
campamento de reeducación
mientras esté la situación es que
sabemos que hay campamentos exactamente
donde hay una represión muy importante
es la sigo los uigures están no pueden
practicar su cultura su religión los
niños están separados de su familia para
ser reeducados a olvidar su cultura su
origen para
estar para
asimilarse en la ciudad asimilarse en la
cultura arrancas la cultura de la etnia
mayor y that y hasta crímenes contra la
humanidad como torturas desaparecidos
desapariciones forzadas y esterilización
forzada de mujeres y este es un signo de
genocidio este llamado internacional
empezó con 180 organizaciones ahora hay
más de 300 en concreto lo que me
interesa a mí saber es cuáles son estas
marcas de empresas cuáles son estas
empresas a las que ustedes están
señalando como responsables de una otra
manera de ser cómplices de la
utilización del uso de el trabajo
forzado de la población google
bueno las informaciones si lo hacen las
investigaciones que tenemos muestran
vínculos comerciales comerciales entre
empresas en esta región y importantes
transnacionales y marcas de europa son
muy conocidas como
inditex que es la empresa que de tiendas
las marcas como zara o pull and bear de
origen español exactamente pero también
nike y adidas un club y tenemos
y otras empresas de otros sectores como
el sector electrónico como apple samsung
y amazon también son varias y son
importantes empresas que tienen las
medidas de conocer las condiciones
laborales en toda la quedada de
producción pero ahora no hay como un
derecho internacional que les les
obligue si a ser responsible y esto es
nuestro combate
y en este sentido justamente lo que
llama mi atención es que varias de las
empresas que usted menciona
concretamente las que tienen que ver con
el calzado deportivo o con la ropa que
usamos regularmente muchas de ellas son
empresas que estuvieron señaladas en su
momento en 2013 si mi memoria no falla
cuando un edificio en bangladesh el
edificio de la plaza se derrumbó dejando
sin vida matando asesinando a más de
1200 personas sí ahí
de estas empresas que eran efectivamente
en la granda plaza y lo que mostrara la
terrible situación de los uigures como
una repetición en el sistema capitalista
culta muy liberal
ahora en el mundo donde las empresas
están libres de
crear ganancias sin regulación y está el
problema que si esto de la impunidad de
las transnacionales hace como más de 10
20 años que sabemos que hay violaciones
de masa en este sector y si no tenemos
leyes derecho de derecho internacional
con un sistema de sanción la situación
va a repetirse volvamos al caso
precisamente con la población we would
hay alguna respuesta se sabe que el
gobierno chino haya reaccionado a este
informe que es bastante fuerte porque
ustedes le están pidiendo a estas
empresas que corten cualquier vínculo y
se comprometan públicamente a evitar el
uso del trabajo forzado esto en un plazo
máximo de un año la reacción de las
empresas hay reacción del gobierno chino
bueno a la reacción de las empresas es
hay dos maneras de responder la primera
es la negación de todo vínculo con esta
región es lo que dijo dice inditex zara
otras empresas dicen que no tienen
pero no dan prueba no
y del otro lado comunican directamente
sobre los redes sociales a los
consumidores que no tienen la
información para saber si lo que dicen
las marcas es la realidad o no y ya es
nuestro papel como ongs como
organizaciones de la sociedad civil de
poner presión de mantener la presión
para que estas empresas firman una
llamada internacional y en en esta
llamada esa es la única prueba de una a
una
de un compromiso de esas empresas no
comunicación sobre las redes sociales
pero la firma de este llamada
internacional
para retirarse de la región y el
gobierno chino es lo mismo hay una
importante negación de lo que pasaba
para el gobierno el trabajo forzado es
forme parte de una reeducación o
presenta este bueno estos signos de
genocidio como una reeducación de
poblaciones que son peligrosas y hay
también reacciones sobre redes sociales
un diputado europeo rafael glücksmann
con quien estamos trabajando porque
tiene una una visibilidad importante
sobre la cuestión
fue también la sibila flexible de
objetos y de del gobierno de los
envasadores por ejemplo o sea que por
ejemplo el gobierno chino es muy fuerte
no ya como una da una batalla
internacional comercial y ahora vamos a
estamos pidiendo a manuel marco a los
gobiernos de europa y que sean más
fuerte en su pedimos al gobierno chino
para este propósito a navidad usted como
colectivo como portavoz del colectivo
electric se le etiqueta la ética sobre
la etiqueta es una de las organizaciones
que más promovió la ley de vigilancia de
vida de las empresas matrices y
subcontratistas que fue aprobada por el
gobierno francés en 2017 y que obliga a
las empresas con más de 10 mil
trabajadores en el mundo a respetar muy
concretamente lo que son los derechos
de esos trabajadores como pueden jugar
esta ley en el caso precisamente de la
utilización de trabajo forzado con la
población muy cool ahora esta ley se
aplica a las empresas que tienen más de
5000 empleados en francia o diesel
internacional y dice que las empresas
están importantes transnacionales no
tienen que publicar y prevenir las
violaciones
publicando un plan de vigilancia y las
medidas que van a poner para que estas
violaciones no ocurren y en este en este
caso se podemos ver si las empresas que
tienen más de cinco mil empleados en
francia o 10.000 al internacional han
hecho este plan plano de vigilancia y si
han puesto la cuestión del trabajador
del trabajo forzado de wilbur y como
como con qué medidas
que implementaron para prevenir esta
violación y en caso que podemos mostrar
el vínculo entre estas violaciones y la
empresa podemos ir en justicia y excitar
a la empresa en justicia y el juez va a
como el valorar y evaluar si están
violaciones este trabajo fuerza
destrozado es debido a una mancha una
falta no a la obligación de vigilancia
de la empresa pero es es un poco difícil
claro pues estamos llegando ya al final
de esta emisión es evidente que hay
soluciones que se pueden aportar no nos
queda sino agradecerle a nayla hay al
tony portavoz del colectivo athletic se
le ticket la ética sobre la etiqueta
miembro del colectivo que llama a luchar
contra el trabajo forzado a los víveres
su presencia en nuestros estudios
gracias a ustedes hasta una próxima cita
en otra escala en parís
[Música]
[Aplausos]